EFFECT.
HE'S BEEN GOOD AWAY FROM THE AL
CAPITALS AND THE RA FOR COPP.
COPP THROUGH TRAFFIC.
THAT GOES OFF A BODY NICE
JOB GOING TO IN THE NATIONAL
HOCKEY LEAGUE.SED
HIMSELF HERE AS HE GIVES THE
PUCK TO AT THE LINE BY
MORRISSEY, TO DU GOAL
FROM PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS.
AGAIN, JUST A NICE JOB ON THE
HUNT.
ON THE FORE-CHECK,
FIRST OPPORTUNITY FROM STASTNY,
AFTER A LOOSE PUCK, EHLERS WILL
BANK NATE
SCHMIDT.
AROUND.
THE WAY THIS SHIFT STARTEDED.
PIXIE DUST ON THAT THE NET.
AND THEN GETSAL MINUTE OF THE
OPENING PERIOD OVERALL FROM 201.
>> Dennis: BUFFALO SABRES DOWN .
ROLLED OFF THE SIDE BOARDS BY
HINOSTROZA.
FOR CODY EAKIN.
EAKIN BACK FEETIT, CAN'T CONTRO.
IN BEHIND THE JETS NET, PIONK
DEFLECTED THAT AWAY A LOOK AT T
GOALS.
DEFENSIVE PLAY,
TIGHT TURN, LOSES THE CHECKININ
25 SECONDS OF THIS SHIFT
DEFENDING AND AT THE ENDTS
>> Dennis: JACOB BRYSON WILL
CARRY INTO THE JETS ZONE.
SKSK ENDS OF THE ICE. AT THE LIE
27-18 FAVOURING THE WINNIPEG
JETS BUT THE SABRES ARE UP BIT.
A MINUTE SIX AFTER THE SABRES
TOOK 2--OFF WILL BE IN THE
JETS LINE AS IT ODD MAN RUSH FO
SABRES. THAT WAS A TWO-ON-ONE.
AND
BANKED JEJTLY OFF THE BOARDS BY
M ASPLUND